Pero se les marcaba con una "S"
para indicar que serían esclavos
una vez que llegaran a EE. UU.
o Europa.
Otro de los objetos que capturaron mi imaginación de joven
fue la túnica del Klan.
Por vivir en Carolina del Sur, me tocó presenciar actos del Ku Klux Klan
en más de una ocasión,
y el recuerdo de esos eventos nunca se borró de mi memoria.
No supe qué hacer con esas imágenes hasta 25 años más tarde.
Hace unos años comencé a investigar sobre el Klan,
sobre sus tres encarnaciones
y en particular la segunda.
La segunda encarnación del Klan tuvo más de 5 millones de miembros activos,
lo cual representaba el 5 % de la población en ese entonces,
o la población total de Nueva York en aquel momento.
La fábrica de túnicas del Klan situada en Buckhead, Georgia, tenía tanta demanda
que funcionaba 24 horas para poder atender a todos los pedidos.
Siempre tenían 20 000 túnicas listas para poder satisfacer la demanda.
Como coleccionista de objetos y como artista
realmente quería una túnica del Klan para mi colección
porque los objetos cuentan historias,
pero no podía conseguir ninguna que fuera realmente de buena calidad.
¿Qué puede hacer un negro en EE. UU.
cuando no consigue una túnica de calidad del Klan?
(Risas)
No tenía otra opción.
Me propuse fabricar las mejores túnicas del Klan en EE. UU.
Estas no son las tradicionales túnicas que se ven los actos del KKK.
Usé tejido kente,
tela de camuflaje,
espándex, arpillera, seda, satén, géneros de distintos estampados.
Las fabrico para gente de diferentes edades, jovencitos
e incluso niños pequeños.
Hasta hice una túnica para bebé.
Después de fabricar tantas túnicas me di cuenta
de que las políticas que el Klan promovía
o que ellos querían implementar cien años atrás
existen hoy en día.
Tenemos escuelas, vecindarios y sitios de trabajos segregados racialmente
pero quienes mantienen vivas estas políticas no llevan estas capuchas.
Mi trabajo tiene que ver con el impacto de la esclavitud a largo plazo.
No solo estamos lidiando con los restos de un racismo sistémico.
Es la base de todo lo que hacemos.
Otra vez estamos segregando intencionalmente vecindarios,
sitios de trabajo y escuelas.
Suprimimos a los votantes.
Hay una representación desproporcionada de minorías en las cárceles.
Tenemos racismo ambiental, brutalidad policial.
Les traje un par de cosas hoy.
La naturaleza encubierta del racismo
es parte de su poder.
Cuando eres discriminado
no siempre puedes demostrar que te están discriminando.
El racismo tiene el poder de esconderse,
y cuando se esconde está seguro
porque no se nota.
Hice esta túnica para ilustrar esta idea.
La base del capitalismo en EE. UU. es la esclavitud.
Los esclavos fueron el capital del capitalismo.
El primer líder oficial del KKK en 1868, Nathan Bedford Forrest,
era un soldado de la Confederación que se enriqueció con la trata de esclavos.
La riqueza como producto de la esclavitud,
de tratar al esclavo como propiedad, era increíble.
Solo la venta de algodón en 1860 equivalía a USD 200 millones.
Hoy en día eso equivale a USD 5 mil millones.
Gran parte de la riqueza que vemos hoy es riqueza heredada.
Ah, y se me olvidaban los otros productos.
Tenemos índigo, arroz y tabaco.
En el 2015 fabriqué una túnica a la semana durante todo el año.
Después de fabricar 75 túnicas tuve una revelación.
Me di cuenta de que existe la supremacía blanca,
pero su mayor promotora no es el KKK
sino la normalización del racismo sistémico.
También me di cuenta de algo más.
Las túnicas ya no tienen el poder de afectarme.
Pero si nosotros, como sociedad,
analizamos estos objetos,
hierros de marcar, grilletes, túnicas,
y aceptamos que son parte de nuestra historia,
entonces lograremos evitar que su poder nos afecte.
Si analizamos el racismo sistémico
y reconocemos que está arraigado en nuestra identidad como país,
entonces podremos hacer algo sobre la segregación racial intencional
en nuestras escuelas, vecindarios y sitios de trabajo.
Solo entonces podremos realmente abordar
y afrontar el legado de la esclavitud
y desmantelar este horrible legado.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)